hello welcome back I want to bring you
some breaking news uh that we've learned
about in the past few minutes it's about
the future of Philip Schofield on this
morning and I can tell you that he has
now stepped down from the ITV program
with immediate effect he's uh hosted or
co-hosted the show for over 20 years a
statement has been put out by the
presenter who is now 61 so he won't be
returning to this morning reports wide
reports of a rift with his co-presenter
Holly Willoughby but this is what Philip
Schofield has had to say by way of this
statement he says I have always been
proud to cover fascinating stories on
this morning but recently this morning
itself has become the story throughout
my career in TV including the very
difficult last few days I have always
done my best to be honorable and kind I
understand that ITV has decided the
current situation can't go on and what I
and I want to do what I can to protect
the show that I love so I have agreed to
step down from this morning with
immediate effect in the hope the show
can move forward to a bright future
Phillip Schofield goes on to say I'd
like to thank everyone who has supported
me especially this morning's amazing
viewers and I'll see you all for the
soap Awards next month so confirmation
in the past few minutes that Philip
Schofield has quit as a co-host of this
morning he's been there since around
2002 first presenting with Fern Britain
and then at latterly with Holly
Willoughby and widespread reports of a
rift between the two in recent weeks
being the subject of much debate in the
past week we also know that Philip
schofield's brother has been jailed to
uh very recently so Philip Schofield
there setting out
his reasons for quitting this morning he
has left the show with immediate effect
and will not be returning